we'll mark the views of ten
but the potholes down that drive are a
serious drawback i may have whiplash
things can only get better front door
ah
[Music]
i don't hear from you for months and
then there's sudden need to sell the
tuscan house by
last tuesday the house has been empty
for 20 years
we just cheer the place up a bit and get
it sold
tuscany is a romantic idol it's why all
my clients come here
you have delivered me a building site
whose walls seem to have been painted by
mussolini i wouldn't go on the bathroom
if i were you
there's a larger weasel in the sink
that's not a euphemism
okay what's flat it's like a rat boat
like
good teeth the size of a baguette like a
rat baguette
you're an holiday i'm actually here to
sell an old family house
i love that house you want to buy it i
can only pay you a risotto
how many balls do you want for it the
way the light hits those windows
takes his breath away no that's the dust
doing that
[Music]
why are you selling it jack's memories
of the house are
not so good
i heard about your mother jack i'm sorry
we live by
one of the two i don't remember anything
you can't remember
but i can't forget
[Music]
this house deserves to have his history
on it
[Music]
everyone lets everyone down at some
point
how you come back from that
that's romance
rough translation very doable
you